Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
January 13th,
2018 what's going on? How, why?
Yeah. How's it going? I know. I'm,
I know I'm late.
I know I'm fucking late.
Like your girlfriend after prom night.
All [inaudible] sorry for the bad joke.
And this is going to be a lot of bad
jokes on this. This is old Billy jet lag.
All right. You know, remember buddy,
love in fucking the nutty professor.
You know, it was a cooler version of
him. Um, I'm not cool on any level,
so it just becomes worse versions of me.
And today you're going to be
listening to old Billy jet lag.
It's five 41 in the morning and
I'd been up for the last two hours.
Uh, you know, I don't, I'm, I'm
on. Yeah, I'm on, I'm back in La.
I'm going, going back
back to Billy. Billy.
I'm all American belly again.
And I'm so glad to be back in a
country that likes Donald Trump.
You know,
it's about time.
And I know there's a few Hollywood people
out here that are trying to make it
seem like there's a bunch of people out
there that don't care for Donald Trump
and it's just simply not the case.
The guy has the highest approval
rating of any president ever.
He has a higher approval rating then.
Then I'll dictators where people are
afraid to say they don't like him.
This is all true stuff. You know, it's
funny as he will quote this podcast as a,
as a fan, as a fact to say
that shit about himself. Um,
all right. I thought I could do my podcast
with my mouth guardian. I can't do it.
Hang on a second. Hang on a
second. All right, I'm back.
I know what you guys are thinking. Like
Jesus Christ. Bill, you're 50 years old.
You still have a mouth guard.
You're still wearing a fucking retainer,
huh? What are you going to use
sophomore semiformal next week? Um, no,
I got that Invisalign and I'm actually,
Yay.
I listened to what the dentist
says, which is, you know,
all these people get Invisalign.
They go through all the fucking,
the pain in the ass shit
of having this stuff.
And then when the second
day I had done that,
give them the mouth guard
and they don't wear it,
and then their teeth gradually
just become trucking again. Not me,
not me.
I'm smarter than that.
Okay.
I pay for this shit,
you know?
But it's like getting your car fixed and
you go out and you fucking sideswipe a
tree.
Why would you do that?
Okay.
You know,
you may not have a lot of things in life,
but if you could have nice straight teeth
that gets you through a lot of stuff,
cops literally show up, you know?
Why did you beat that woman?
I didn't beat her. Oh, look at his
big shiny teeth. Hey Sweetheart,
what were you wearing that made
them do that? That's what happens.
That's how you get out of it.
Um, anyways, I'm very, very, uh,
happy to come back. My, Oh my God,
my daughter gave me like four.
The greatest hugs I've ever gotten in
my life when I got home. It was awesome.
And it's so weird, you know, when
they're that little, they hug gear,
but then immediately I want to go run
and go do something else, you know,
and Gosh, she doesn't even care.
And then she kept coming back,
hugging me before she'd go run back
over to a toy. So it was pretty, uh,
it was pretty awesome. Uh,
we finished the tour strong.
Um,
I don't even know what the hell last day
I talked to you where the hell I was.
I don't know. I want to say I was
on my way to pull in, was it Warsaw?
Berlin? Yeah, Prague and then Vienna.
And um,
all of them would just,
they were amazing or so we went there and,
uh,
I actually talked to Versie for his,
he has a patrion page as do I.
And I did a little quick
half hour podcast with him.
The only one of the only country that
we met on this trip was in Warsaw at our
hotel was a place that kind
of looked like a restaurant,
kind of looked like a cafe.
And we went in there and
we were immediately told
by the waiter that it was a
chocolate factory. He kept
saying that like, we are looking,
we wanted to get something to eat and
they had all this chocolate shit there,
but they also had sandwiches and stuff
like that. So verse, he says to him,
he goes like, Hey, so uh, what
would you say is your, uh,
what would you recommend? What's the best
thing on? And he goes, what did he say?
He said, uh, chocolate to make it easy.
If I could, if I could sum it
up, chocolate, like a, all right,
we want some sandwiches. Is, is this a
good sandwich? He's like, yeah, yeah,
it's good. It's good.
It's like that. Right?
Then he just kept having a fucking comment
on everything that we were going to
do after we ate. He goes, you want
something else? He wants something else.
And I go, AH, right. You know, maybe
I'll get a hot chocolate or something.
Then you'd be like, you showed
you have room. It's like, well,
if you don't think I'm think up too
full after, what the fuck I ate,
why would you ask me you fucking
skinny con. He was such a fucking cunt.
He was such a cunt. So then
I go up to, I said, you know,
I'll get some hot chocolate. He
goes, well, Vince Vaughn, we have,
okay the [inaudible], we are a chocolate
factory. It's like, no, do not a factory.
You're not making the chocolate
here. You stupid skinny. Can't,
you know I am this upset about it
was cause I kept thinking like, oh,
I'm being the ugly American.
Maybe I should be even nicer to this guy.
And the nice dry was the more of a Canty
was. And then in the end, you know,
when he was such a con, Versie
got mad first. He never gets mad.
I'll get mad at fucking net on that.
Fucking Goddamn by peacock for
some reason popped in my head.
First is trying to think
pigeon. Um, oh my God,
that guy is a temper. He got mad
at a peacock, um, even verse,
he was upset by the end.
And then when I saw him getting upset,
I realized how ridiculous was that. I
was getting upset. I just said, Paul,
he works in a chocolate factory.
We're going to go tell jokes and a
fucking basketball arena in Warsaw.
And uh, so then we both laughed and were
like, all right buddy, take it easy,
you know?
And I gotta tell you though,
the hot chocolate was the shit they get
came over with a little trio of them.
One of them, one of the hot chocolates
was white. It's like white chocolate,
you know, which was,
which was, uh, you know,
should have been my nickname when I
played basketball, but I wasn't good.
So that kid from Sacramento got it.
Then there was another one
was just chocolate chocolate,
and then it was coffee chocolate
and I fucking hate coffee.
So I gave that DePaul the white
chocolate was fucking bananas.
So the guy comes over and I'm
still trying to be friendly
and uh, I got all the hot chocolate
was delicious and he's like, really?
And I was like, yeah, this one here. And
I pointed to the white one. That one was,
it was fucking amazing. Right. I
didn't say amazing. Fucking amazing.
I said it was amazing. And he goes, oh,
he must have a sweet tooth. Oh, sorry.
Okay. All right. You know,
he was like so skinny.
You could have beaten
him with his own body.
Yeah.
He was like, he was like, like a
nightstick with a fucking head.
Um, is, does a chocolate fan.
Oh, Ben versus he went up
to after his, cause he had,
you know, a burger, whatever
the fuck you guys can I get,
just get a piece of chocolate and the
guys, I guess you could just want one.
You're going to get, eat it so fast.
The first he's like, I just want one.
You know, you know, they all over
there. They fan from World War Two.
They have like the, you know, the butcher
of Baghdad or some shit like that,
which is the Middle East. You know, we
would joke and he was the kind of Warsaw,
but as Conti as he was and is frustrated
as I was that I couldn't find a little
Polish flag. You know, that's what I
do. When I go on the road, I find those,
you know, those things that back in the
day people would, so until like a jacket,
I'm not doing that. I'm
going to frame him. Um,
I got to have some sort of framework
and open and close it where, you know,
cause it's a work in progress where I'm
going to go and I'm just want to keep
adding to it.
And uh,
I couldn't get the Polish flag because
I took a picture of the collage of them
and put it on Instagram.
A lot of people gave me shit because I
didn't have the Polish flag or the German
flag. I already have a German flag.
I'd already been to Cologne before.
That's why I didn't have that and I didn't
have the Polish flag because I simply
could not find a place,
a souvenir place in the time allotted.
I went down into the subway,
the od, the bound and um,
they literally had a Polish flag
and they had magnets and shit,
but they didn't have the other one.
So I'm just going to order
one off the internet today,
today, today, today, today.
Um,
so anyways,
then we went out and did the show and
it was in like this fucking basketball
arena and which it was,
it was fucking unbelievable.
The tour was great, but somewhere when
it, somewhere in Latvia and then Budapest,
it just went to another level.
Um,
and then the rest of the
tour, I, I, you know,
I was in Budapest on stage going like,
I think I would shoot a special here.
And when I went to a Warsaw, we were in
this little basketball arena type thing.
Um, and they had a stool
and that this the, you know,
the seat was all fucked up and
I just started making fun of it,
going to come out war. So come
on, you can do better than that.
And they had a great sense of humor about
themselves. I just, you know, I dunno,
it was just one of those things
I riffed on the stool and just,
just went from there.
Then I went to Berlin,
did a little shopping for the
ladies in my life, you know,
try to find them some sneakers and shit.
And it was incredible.
You went there and they had like this
whole sort of like the Saks fifth avenue
of Berlin in, in the middle of all that,
I should post a picture. They had, um,
this beautiful church that was built
before the time of World War II and it was
all bombed out.
Like one of the spires was busted off the
top of it and it was like bullet holes
and everything in it and they kept it,
it turns it into a store
or something like that.
But it was a reminder of World War Two
and right next to it was this ultra
modern building that they were making.
It was really a really interesting and uh,
I would like to go back,
okay,
there again soon. And the next time
I do Germany and I go into Warsaw,
as I mentioned before, that never wanted
to go to Auswitch or anything like that.
But now I kind of went down this rabbit
hole and I was looking up all of that
stuff.
And as much as you don't want to go
there to see that level of fucking evil,
it's kind of a good thing
to be reminded that,
you know, an entire nation of people can
be talked into some shit like that. Um,
and another thing that blew my mind
was when we were in Nuremberg. Um,
and I know it's still want
to make Germany. Yeah,
this is all that it is because the food
was fucking great. The people were great.
But uh, there is that fascination.
So they have a field there.
Zeplin field,
I believe it's called,
and it's not led Zepplin like literally
the guy who invented the Zipline,
I think landed there and that's where
they had those giant Nazi fucking rallies,
um, way back in the day.
And that place still exists.
They've taken down all the pillars,
but you could just walk in there and
literally stand where Hitler and all those
fucking lunatic stood.
And um,
I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck it is over there.
I wanna just like the beaches of
normally do you just go there?
It's just a beach,
but it's a really like fucking emotional
thing when you go there like Jesus
Christ and then you see
like what was stopped,
how great that is. But now you see
where the fuck that we've ended up.
And it's just really a, you know, human
beings were, were extreme where uh,
you know, we're kind of like at the
Jaguar in the, in the uh, or the Jaguar,
however you say saying a mid
eighties Jaguar, you know,
it's a great fucking car,
you know, it's beautiful and all of that,
but it fucking breaks down all the time.
It always needs to be fixed.
Um, and I was teasing him over
in Germany about that shit.
I was quick to tell them that we've,
my country has done everything that
you guys have done. We just fucking,
it's just wasn't filmed.
You know what I'm saying?
Which is weird cause I go when
I go over to Germany and shit,
I was talking about this, how I sit there
and think like, oh my God, this is like,
you know,
Hitler,
he gave a speech here and there was a
concentration camp over there. But when,
you know,
I'm down south,
I don't think when I'm at a waffle
house that maybe this would used to be a
plantation and someone got fucking
beaten to death. There were,
they were running away from their
slave man, I never think of that shit.
Or this is where native Americans were
and they would just sort of hanging out.
We fucking came in and
murdered all of them. Oh,
isn't this a fun podcast? Um, so anyways,
after Berlin we then went down to the
Czech Republic and I performed in this
theater that was basically where
they would have all the, the uh,
the, uh, the communist rallies,
you know, in communism is yet
another thing that gets a bad rap.
Communism gets a bell. It does work. It
does Burger. It's like none of them work.
None of them work because they
work in theory, in theory. Hey man,
everybody has the same stuff man.
And everybody lives community.
That works if everybody buys in,
but they don't cause it's always constant,
the top that want fucking more. And then
there's also people who think, well,
you know, if there's no reward for
fucking working harder than somebody else,
I'm just going to coast con.
Right?
And then you have capitalism a whoever's
the fucking best fuck and the bad,
the bad. They're going to fucking the,
and it's, that's not how it works.
It's not how it works.
Whoever's the best whatever will now be
absorbed by a corporation or crushed is
how it works. And um, I don't know
if you think it's fucking working,
you're not paying attention
to our bottom line right now.
This country is bankrupt and has been
bankrupt since fucking 2008 as far as I
can tell. And everybody's just
ignoring it. I mean, Jesus Christ,
Clemson won the national championship.
They go to the White House and they
got fucking Domino's and Wendy's
and everybody's blaming Donald Trump.
Like,
what kind of a fucking asshole does that?
And they're blaming the shutdown.
It's like gay guys, we are bankrupt. Okay.
This is what poor people eat.
They eat fast food. All right,
I'm sorry. That's a wakeup call to
where the fuck we're at right now.
But we are fucking bankrupt and I don't
agree with a lot of shit that Trump's
doing,
but if that guy can somehow get us out
of these fucking wars so we can begin to
try and figure out how to pay him
back. I mean, I, I don't, I don't know.
Uh, yeah, I don't get
like whatever. I mean,
I know what the fuck
we're doing over there.
Everybody knows what the fuck we're
doing over there and then everybody knows
what we're saying that we're doing over
there and it's two completely fucking
different. Um, anyways,
I don't want to get on a
whole fucking thing. It,
cause I don't pay
attention to enough of it.
But it seems to me that we are fucking,
we spent $1 trillion to stop 3,500 fucking
jerk offs is what we're doing now on
a jungle gym that don't have a planer,
a fucking boat.
And we'd gone bankrupt doing that
in like a half a dozen corporations,
made a zillion dollars off of it and
continued to try and keep us over there
cause they also own media.
So no one is,
hopefully people will begin to
talk about this shit cause uh,
I know this doesn't sound patriotic
because now patriotism is just support the
troops. I support the troops, you
know, and if you don't have, you know,
support the troops, get the fuck out
of the country. And it's like, okay,
I support the troops,
but can I logically talk financially
what the fuck we've done so that our kids
are kids, kids are kids, kids, kids, kids,
kids all the way down the line won't
still be paying for this fucking thing.
MMM.
And you know what? I am open to discussion
here. Let's, let's fucking open this up.
We got the call,
we got the fucking lines open.
Can Somebody please explain
to me financially how
we're going to get out from
underneath us?
MMM.
I did feel good when I was in Germany
that they were going to switch to
renewable energy,
which I think is the solution to Middle
Eastern terrorism because it seems all
the oil money that they make up for oil
is funneled through the mosque and then
financed to these groups that we
don't like that want to kill us.
So if we stopped buying their oil,
they count have any money and then
they don't even have a jungle gym.
Is that, is that too? I'm sure that's
too simple, but I do this a lot.
I say ignorant shit and then
people straighten me out.
So I ask is that if you think I'm way off
base and right now you're screaming at
your fucking windshield,
calm the fuck down and just explain to
me how our space I am and I will listen.
I can be swayed.
I don't have confidence in my opinion.
I deliver it with confidence. But in
the back of my book, my head, there's,
there's always that voice be a pill.
You don't read, you don't read books.
All right? So we went to, uh,
we went to Prague and we,
uh,
we performed at this place where I
imagined Bresch Never Gorbachev fits,
spoke at.
And I got such a kick out of being in
there is far as like all the shit talk.
And that must've been done about
the United States of America.
And I was Sorta refund imitating them
comrade. They don't have fat over there.
They have fat and they fucked
her six sisters, all that shit.
And then I was there
telling my Dick Jokes,
but that crowd was fucking unbelievable
and they just rolled with everything.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I haven't felt that much.
I haven't had that much fun on fucking
stage in forever because of what's going
on with stand up comedy.
I actually was able to get away.
I kept tagging all of my jokes
going and if I said that in America,
my career would be over.
And they all laughed.
They all laughed, you know. So, once
again, as I stated in my last podcast,
comedians, okay, we're, you know,
we need to stick up for each other.
We don't need to be taking
each other down about material.
There's literally comedians going online
tweeting about people's material and
saying, maybe they
shouldn't, they're there.
Everybody's Comedians are turning
into Al Gore's wife. You know,
when she used to attack heavy metal, like
I don't know what the fuck is going on,
but for the love of God,
shut up, use your head,
cause you're chopping
your own fucking head off.
Eventually that shit is the water's gonna
rise up around your ankles and you can
eventually you're going to drown in
the bullshit that you're creating here.
So anyways, we were over there, had
a great show, we found a cigar bar,
um, smoked a wonderful partake agis
party guests are the fuck you say.
Um, tomato, tomato. And then we went
back to the hotel room and be like,
can you imagine if the fucking
Kansas City colts game was on?
And they had this sports channel seven,
they are over there and we got it and
we fucking lost our minds. And it like,
you know, midnight over there,
we were watching the second,
third and fourth quarter. No,
because we watched the second half.
So we kind of missed all the scoring.
Um,
and I would say this,
I will say this,
the Patriots game and the chiefs game,
uh,
both of those defenses that you saw,
the Patriots' defense and the chief's
defense, every, it's like, wow,
what's going on? These guys really figured
something out. What you were seeing,
there was two teams that were just
totally out coaching the other team.
They had a game plan that worked and
the other team could not adjust to it.
All right. The chief's defense
is not as good as it looked.
The Patriots' defense is not as
good as it looked against the colts.
That's what I took away from both
of those fucking games. So, um,
I'm an old school guy. I know that the
game is played a different way now. Uh,
when you go for two point convergence,
it's with an entire fucking quarter left.
Um,
I know it's all about offense,
but I still believe that defense wins
Superbowls despite last year's Superbowl.
You know, if you really look
at it all, all, you know,
they only needed to
make one defensive play.
One big defensive play was made
and that changed the game. So, um,
I dunno,
I am definitely skeptical as to whether
the Patriots or the chiefs can win the
Superbowl with their defenses.
Um, having said that,
uh,
I'm very excited for this match up the
rematch and the Patriots have to go into
arrowhead after already beating the Kansas
city chiefs by the skin of our teeth
letting up 40, 41 points. Was
it 44 40 or something like that.
Um,
even though we them last time it was
by no means impressive defensively,
you know, which is why, you
know, we beat the chargers.
Somebody wrote, had this hilarious
tweet where they said, okay,
you know, it's the poor
chargers, you know,
it's so difficult to find a
quarterback that can beat Tom Brady.
And then they had a picture of,
of Eli Manning when he first got drafted
by the charges holding up the jerseys.
And then of course,
all these other fans rather than getting
the joke that the joke was making fun
of the chargers decision to get ready.
Eli Manning,
forget about drew Brees,
um, someone's world, um,
and then showed a picture of nick falls
and it's like they weren't talking about
the eagles and that's,
that is something that does bug me
though as a patriots fan that people are
trying to say nick foals beat Tom Brady.
He didn't,
he beat the fucking Patriots' defense.
All right.
Cause if you look them at the Patriots,
you know,
Brady versus falls Brady only through,
I mean foals only through for like 300
something yards breakthrough for over 500
fucking yards and lost
fucking ridiculous.
So having said that,
maybe the Patriots and the chiefs
may be one of them could win that,
the Superbowl. But my pick has been
the fucking New Orleans saints,
which I was really nervous about
when they were down 14 to nothing.
And I love nick false.
I fucking love that guy.
That guy he plays, you know,
he's one of those, he's like,
he liked the bigger the game is the
better that guy plays and the bullshit way
that that organization keeps
putting him on the fucking bench.
Cause they got so much money
invested I guess in Carson Wentz.
Not saying that that guy's bad
cause he did great, but you know,
a lot of people would demand a
trade or something like that.
He just fucking sits there and it's like,
hi,
when do you need me and when you do I'm
going to go in and crush it. So, um,
I dunno,
it was kind of funny though,
watching Eagle fans all patting themselves
on the back about how great they are
because they weren't sending death
threats to that wide receiver who had the
ball go through his, his
hands, which is a great thing.
And it was impressive that they
didn't do that, but they got a little,
they got a little ahead of
themselves about how great they are.
They kind of forget that they
have the jail in their stadium.
They kind of forget that an entire row
of eagle fans thinks nothing of beating
up a father who's there with his child
because he has a different jersey on or
spitting on him or puking on him.
Oh, throwing shit. Just, you know,
take it down a little bit.
Eagles fans are such assholes.
They actually think they're good people
for the simple fact that they didn't
send it death threat.
You know what you guys sound like,
you sound like feminists right now.
The only one you didn't
do is call yourself brave.
He dropped the ball and we didn't
send death. Threats were so brave.
We're where warriors, um, anyways,
sorry to Eagle nation.
Tough fucking loss. Um,
I was loving what even though you
were going to fuck up my pick,
I was loving what you guys were doing,
um,
when it was 14 to nothing and um,
yeah,
you know,
you did defending super bowl champions
and I felt you weren't getting your
respect the same way.
I can't say the Patriots deserve respect
this year and we've taken some brutal
losses,
but it was in the back of my head.
I was kind of hoping that the Patriots
and the eagles would both make it
mmm.
To the super bowl again,
just to shut all these fucking people up,
but we shall see. All
right. Having said that,
we have to go into Arrowhead stadium,
the loudest fans in the league,
they don't need a stadium
that is architecturally
designed to make them sound
louder than they really are.
They are fucking loud as shit.
They are so fucking sick of the Patriots.
They always beat us,
you know, early in the season or give us
a good game. And every year it's like,
this is the year it's going to be over.
I told you that guy, that guy I saw on,
uh,
I was in that sports bar in New York
City and that guy was just screaming,
this is, it's all over.
This is what it is now.
And he was losing his shit about
wanting to beat the patriots,
who's a chiefs fan.
And he just kept yelling sporadically
and then it just became nonstop yelling
until he was tapped on the shoulder,
ask to go. He got up peacefully,
put his coat on and continued to
scream at the TV right out into public.
And I was just sitting there being like,
wow man,
that's how much people hate the Patriots.
And also I've been there as you know,
back when the old school patriots fans,
certainly a red sox fan and a Bruins fan
when we couldn't beat the Canadians and
all of that shit. So I kind of knew
what that guy was going for. So
it's going to be a weird game where I
want to see the Patriots win obviously.
But if the chiefs go to the
Super Bowl, uh, that'll be
really, really fucking cool.
I mean, they have not been there
since fucking Superbowl for everybody.
67 68, 69, 1970
mmm.
64 toss power trap, right. Hank scramp
way the fuck back then when they played,
played the Vikings, um, super
bowl for what are we up to now?
Superbowl 50 something.
I've even lost track and I'm a fucking
nerd about this shit. So with that, oh,
and the rams, the rams beat the cowboys.
I missed that game. And then I miss the,
uh, I missed another game. I
forgot what the other, no, I don't,
I think I saw both AFC games. I saw
parts of three of four of them. Um,
but now I am back. I'm
back when, you know, it's,
you know what's Hilarious is,
uh,
I have a birthday party you have to go
to for a very special in my own daughter
coming up this week.
So I'm going to be missing some of the
playoffs because old daddy makes the,
I make a birthday cake from scratch
every year. That's what I'm going to do.
And I get, I got to do that. You know,
you got to do shit like that. Um,
anyways. All right. So
yeah,
I took a bunch of Saunas when I was
over there in Europe and uh, oh,
I didn't even talk about the cities by
the way. And even talking about Vienna,
then I go to Vienna in Vienna,
had like this incredible fucking theater
and this club owner to the club owners.
Okay.
They were just the nicest people ever.
And they were feeding us
like an Italian grandmother,
like I even know what that is.
The way verse he always described,
it just would not say no, just
kept bringing out, you know,
Vino Schnitzel, Lynn and, and
then all these desserts, you know,
I love all desserts over there is like a
tray of cheese or like something sugary
and it was just,
yeah,
it was unbelievable.
I think I consumed like 3000 calories,
but it's European calories,
so it's not like the poison over here.
So I woke up the next day being like,
how am I not fatter? Oh, that's right.
I got out from under my own food
supply, so I want to thank them too. Um,
Prague, I gotta tell
you, Prague and Budapest,
a lot of American sleep on those cities.
Um,
okay.
Absolutely gorgeous.
Like I would say even Prague is like
the Paris of the Midwest of Europe.
As far as my little, you know, I didn't
get to see too much of it, but just,
yeah.
You know, driving from the
airport and looking at it,
it was like both of those cities
were a, were breathtaking. And, um,
okay.
All right. My stupid computer keeps
shutting down here. Um, anyways.
Okay.
I watched the rest of pappy onto
the original one when I came back,
when I flew back, man, that
was fucking incredible.
And then I watched this two
hour documentary, which I
forget what it was called,
okay.
About the crossfit championships.
Okay.
And it mainly focused on the women and
stuff like that. And uh, you know what,
like I said earlier where I
could be wrong about our, our uh,
yeah,
our foreign policy.
I think I was wrong about crossfit.
I'm watching what those people
were able to do physically,
but as an old man watching it,
I'm just going like,
I don't know how long these people's
bodies are going to last doing that. Um,
all of those fucking squats
and all of that shit with you,
Charlotte was all I was thinking. Knees
and shoulders, knees and shoulders,
you need those for the rest of your life.
However,
I think stem cell research is going
to get to the point where everyone's,
you know,
all their religious shit is going to go
by the wayside to just have the fucking
knees and shoulders of an 18
year old when you're 60. Um,
I'm telling you right now, there is going
to be some fucking jacked older people
in the future.
I got a buddy of mine,
he had a torn rotator cuff and he got
that shit injected in there and he doesn't
even have scar tissue.
It's fucking crazy. Um,
do I sound like a crazy person right
now I'm talking about foreign policy and
fucking stem cell research lab.
This is, this is all jet lag, Billy.
He's all over the fucking
map. Um, all right,
let me do a couple of reads and then I'm
going to tell you what it was like to
take a sauna in Germany.
All right. Um, okay. Butcher box.
A butcher blocks delivers healthy
100% grass fed, grass finished beef,
free range, orange chicken and the, the,
the the top shelf heritage bread.
Pork.
All right,
this is pure bred pigs that you can
trace the bloodline back to Europe.
All right. Fucking Rudolf Hess.
What an eighth is fucking poor.
The incredible quality of
butcher box. I, you know,
I did Rudel I didn't know that Rudolph
has, he left before all the evil,
evil shit went down. He was there
for the beginning of the evil,
like the game plan of it.
But before the final solution was,
was even put into place,
he fucking got on a plane and left.
They went to Scotland and there's all
this shit about whether Hitler knew he was
going to do it or if he deserted.
He went up there and tried to
make peace with England. It,
Winston Churchill was like,
no, and not making peace.
Go Fuck yourself and arrest this cunt.
And then he spent the rest of his life
in jail and then killed himself allegedly
at 93 where some people thought that
he was, uh, he was strangled. You know,
there's always people being or whatever.
But anyways,
one of the great quotes of all time when
Rudolph has got an a plane and flew up
to Scotland in the middle of
the war to try and make peace.
Hitler's close quote about Rudolf
Hess was, that guy's insane.
Okay.
I mean, that's just one of the
greatest fucking quotes ever.
Adolf Hitler called somebody insane.
That goes back to when I first
started in this business.
It was right around the time when
my favorite drummers of all time,
Steven Adler got kicked out of guns
and roses and their thing was, yeah,
he's doing too many drugs and
every comic had the joke. How many?
How much drugs are you doing
that the other members that
guns and roses go, yeah,
we got to get rid of this guy. He's
partying too much. That was, you know
that that was the guns and roses
version of when Hitler said,
Hey, Rudolph has is insane. All right.
All right. Back to butcher box, everybody.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meets starts with the commitment to start
with the commitments are raising animals
humanely and free of antibiotics and
hormones before they killed him.
Cook with Pete, the peace of mind,
of knowing you're eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least
eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is for 24 individual size meals.
If you have the discipline,
you know,
if you eat like that guy in seven who
ended up face down in his spaghetti o's,
I mean you're going to, you're going
to go through that shit in a week. Um,
you can choose from five different
box types. All beef, beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box,
a custom box which lets you
choose your own cuts. Uh,
my favorite box cut is
I'm supposed to say,
I would say I'd have to go beef
and pork or maybe I go mix box
by like custom box too. You know,
I like a custom car. I Dunno.
Yeah,
I dunno because they just keep sending
me the shit for free cause they're liking
the way I'm reading this stuff.
Anyways.
Oh now we're announcing our new brand
of protein, what they find a new animal,
a wild Alaskan Salmon,
butcher box sources, sources.
They're pure, sustainably harvested
salmon from Bristol Bay, Alaska.
Unlike any salmon you'll find in
your local store, literally is,
it's red color means that this salmon is
as fresh and nutrient rich as it gets.
For $20 off your first box
in two pounds of free salmon,
go to butcher box.com/burn enter bur bur
that's butcher box.com enter burr and
introvert. Sorry. You know what's
funny? I got, I got so sick of,
I'm watching comedians attacking
other comedians on Twitter and,
and people screaming about Trump that I,
I found somehow I find this place
where you could like maybe follow some
different things on Twitter.
So I decided to go into the science world.
Okay.
Like this will fascinate me.
I'm such a poor science background.
Let me fucking read up on this shit.
Right?
And all they did was talk about how
we're destroying the environment.
And it was even more depressing than
listen to fucking morons yelling about
politics as I on this politics.
Politics on this podcast gave you my
solution for solving the Middle East
problems. I mean, how
Hypocritical Ama. So anyways,
I went on there and I found out some
snail, just the last one they called him.
George out in Hawaii has now died.
Okay.
And uh, evidently those things are going
to go extinct. stamps.com everybody
stamps.com is the faster and more
convenient way to get postage.
Simple. Use Your computer to print
official US postage for any letter,
any package, any class of mail,
anywhere you wanted to send it.
And the mail carrier picks it up.
No more lugging mail to the post office.
No more hassles man. With stamps.com
you get discounted postage rates,
uh, that you can't even
get at the post office.
Not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters and
there's no equipment to at least
and no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com to send out
all my posters, Christmas gifts.
It's great. It's great. And right now,
and I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you, and right now
you too can enjoy Stan stock,
the stamps.com service with a special
offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale. So start the
new year off, right. Go to stamps.com.
Click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
enter
burr. All right, before I
do the reads this week, um,
I took a sauna when I was in,
uh,
Germany and evidently they,
I heard that they were naked. They go
into those saunas naked and it's coed.
So I asked for Z if he wanted to go
down to the sign and he said yes.
And then I texted him, he must've fell
asleep. So I said, fuck. I went down,
I worked out,
got a great workout in,
and then I went to go into the sun and
there was nobody in there. And the old me,
I like the steam. Now I really liked the
dry sauna because it can get way hotter.
You know, Joe Rogan converted me, right?
So I go in there and I went in there
like an American, I have my slippers on,
I had my towel on and all of that shit.
And then all of a sudden this dude comes
walking in, he has a towel on. I'm like,
oh, thank God, thank God it's
Berlin. Okay, it's brilliant. Okay,
this is like they're in New York City so
everybody is going to act accordingly.
And then he just immediately takes his
towel off and I'm like, what the fuck?
So then he lays and then lays down.
And what he did was he put his outside
leg, the leg close to me, he put it up.
So he was sort of covering his junk,
slashed,
looked like he was getting ready to do,
recreate the Burt Reynolds
playgirls center full.
Right.
So anyways,
and I know this is going to be the fucking
Photoshop. So I'm sitting there like,
yeah, what the fuck? All right. Whatever
one they could do it. Who gives a shit?
Right? And then all of a sudden another
guy comes in and this guy comes in,
he does, he have his towel on. He's just
holding his towel in front of his junk.
Then he goes in like it was
shaped like a horse shoe,
you know like the old fucking a
Denver Bronco Stadium back in the day.
So I'm on one side of the horse shoe.
I'm on like the visitor's side.
The first naked dude is on the fucking
home site and then this naked guy comes
in and he lays down the same way.
Same playgirl fucking thing
with the outside leg up.
He's sitting in the end zone seats. All
right. And I'm like Jesus fucking Christ.
So now I'm laughing cause all I'm thinking
is I to tell versus he cause at this
point it's just naked guys and
just naked guys. It's just funny.
I used to put in my act, a naked
man is either funny or scary, right?
If you're at a football game and a naked
guy jumps out of the crowd and runs
across the field,
you're laughing your ass off.
If you're walking home late at night,
then naked guy jumps out
of the fucking bushes.
It's one of the scariest things ever.
So this was just funny. I'm in a gym,
there's all kinds of
people around or whatever,
even though it's just the three of us in
there. But you know, I can just get up,
walk out the fucking door. There's no
danger here. There's two naked guys.
It's fucking hilarious.
So I'm looking down at the floor
and all I'm thinking about as,
I can't wait to tell version
of this fucking story.
They both lay in here and like fucking
twin Burt Reynolds and sitting here with
my slippers on and my towel,
I don't know.
So anyways,
and then all of a sudden the door opens
again and now a woman comes walking in
and I'm looking,
I kind of look at the guys like,
are they going to cover themselves up?
And they don't.
And then she comes in and just
takes her fucking towel off.
Yeah.
Oh,
just like what the fuck?
And then she sits down in the
end zone seats. All right,
so above her and the upper deck is this
naked guy to her left as the other naked
guy.
She's naked and now,
and she looks over at me and
I got a towel on his slippers.
So now I'm looking like the Weirdo. Now
I'm the fucking pervert. Like, look,
did this fucking guy, we're all getting
naked while you sitting over there. Right?
So now I'm like, well, I
gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
And just as I said that
the dude in the home seat,
he stands up and he's going to walk
out and I'm like, all right, perfect.
Now he's going to use the shower.
I'm just going to wait till
he's done with the shower,
then I'm going to fucking walk out. So
that's exactly what happens. I walk out,
but when I walk out, what I forgot to
mention was they had like, you know,
those ice baths that like NFL
players go to get into, um, bad,
something like that. But there wasn't
ice. It was just like, uh, it was a tank.
You climbed up like six steps and then
climb down into this thing and it was
freezing fucking cold right
after the sauna. Right.
And just closes up all your pores.
It gets rid of all the fucking
toxins and all of that.
All the shit washes off you.
Granted everybody else is using it.
So it's probably fucking gross
on some level. I have no idea.
Maybe because it's so cold, it
kills the shit. I don't know what.
So I wanted to use it,
but there was no way I was gonna use it
because I had to get up to the top of it
and take my towel off,
would be standing up there with my
fucking man who had twisted in the breeze
before I went down into
the fucking Arctic water.
But when I came out there was nobody
there. So I was like, I gotta,
I gotta try it. So I fucking
scampered up the ladder quickly,
took my towel off and then went
down into it and I was like, fuck.
It was freezing cold when all the way
up to like my neck and wanted to stay
there for a minute, but probably only
stayed there for like 15 seconds.
It was enough for me.
But plus also I knew other people were
going to come in and I didn't want to
come crawling out of
there completely naked,
like fucking Jason Alexander now with
my fucking junk all pulled up into me.
Right.
Okay.
Oh
the other dude's in the shower.
I could hear him.
So now I go to get out
of this fucking thing.
I get my towel on and everything and I
feel fucking amazing to go from that heat
to that call. Now I'm going to go into
the shower. It was fucking amazing.
So again,
out of the shower now all I want to
do is tell Versie the fucking story.
It'd be like, dude, even a chick
came in, this is fucking nuts.
And I reached into my robe and
I can't find my key to my locker
and like where the fuck is it?
Drop it with a foot and I'm looking
all around and I was in last time I
remembered having it.
I was holding it in my hand when I was
in the sauna because I didn't want to
leave it in the pocket of
my robe for some reason,
I didn't see like the band that
you could put it around your wrist.
I just didn't, you know,
I'm an idiot. And I saw,
I was just holding onto it and I suddenly
realized that it was still in the
fucking sauna.
Okay.
So now I have to go back into the sauna.
So I go back in there with my head down
with my fucking slippers on and my towel
on and I go back in there and the naked
woman is now laying down sideways facing
the door.
Okay.
Laying down where I was
sitting and I'm like,
I can't go over there with
my towel and be like, Hey,
I'm just looking for my keys. All
right there sweetheart. Right.
It felt like a fucking Weirdo.
So now I sat down,
she's sitting on the
fucking visitor's side.
Now I'm on the home side or whatever.
I might have fucked up
these things you don't want.
I mean I'm sitting on the opposite
side that I was sitting on
and I'm just sitting there
going, all right, well she was,
she's been in here for like 10 minutes.
She's going to fucking leave soon.
And when she does, I'm going to look
for my keys and she just won't leave.
She won't leave.
Yeah.
And then finally I just have to get up
cause I'm dying cause this is my second
trip.
And then I find when I say I'm sorry,
I think I left my key over here
and she's like, Oh I didn't see it.
And she's like sitting up
like fucking naked. Right.
Okay.
So now I go back over and I just fucking
sit down. No, I fucked up the story.
Okay.
I'm sitting down there going,
what the fuck do I do now because I'm
dying to heat. And then all of a sudden
this couple comes walking in
and then they both get naked.
Now there's two naked
women are naked dude.
And then me all covered up.
And at this point now I
feel like a fucking Weirdo
Joe. I'm like, well fuck it.
I'm a Germany.
So now I take my towel off
and I'm just sitting there cracking up,
fucking laughing. Like, you know that you,
he just looked down and you just,
you know what it's like,
I'm gonna laugh my ass off,
but nobody's going to know.
So you don't make a sound and
you don't change your face,
you just have your mouth open
and you just kind of go, like,
I was literally doing that
while I was so fucking hot.
I could feel my heartbeat in my ears.
Okay.
So at some point it just got so
hot and she wasn't leaving and it,
she was like a pro.
So I finally just got up and I just sort
of had my towel cover myself and go,
I'm sorry. I think I left my cue over. And
she goes, oh, I did not see it. The BOBA.
Okay.
And I go, all right. So then I went
back and I sat down. That's what I did.
That's when I sat down and then she got
up and I was like, still going to go.
It's gotta be underneath or something.
So I waited for her to leave.
I toughed it out and then I walk over
there and I'm feeling around on the
fucking seats and shit
and it's just not there.
And they have the slats and I'm like,
it probably fell down in between it.
Now I'm going to have to walk
out with just my and robot,
go back to the front desk, pay
the fee, and all of this shit.
So now I walk out of the Sauna.
I'm fucking almost passing out
and to my left and my peripheral,
I see that woman again naked at the top
of the fucking ladder to go into the ice
bath. I'm like, Jesus fucking Christ.
I gotta get Outta here. Right?
And as I'm walking away,
you know [inaudible] I hear her
yelling over to somebody and I'm like,
I know she's not talking to me.
And then she just goes,
then she switches to English and she goes,
did you find your key?
And I kind of have turned but didn't
look at it and I go, no, no, I didn't.
And then she goes, is this it? And I
realized I had bets where I left it.
When I scampered up the
ladder to go there, I left
it at the top of the iceberg.
I go, Oh yeah it is. And then she stays
at the top of the ladder and just,
you know,
kinda hands.
And I walk over and literally her vagina
is above me and I kind of reached up,
like looking but not looking
dog has shade.
And that was so fucked up.
I didn't even take a shower and I just
walked out and I went to the locker room
and I went in there and I was like pouring
sweat and everyone was looking at me
like, well divided these shower
off. He's all red, like the tomato.
Um, anyways. And then I just,
I put my shit back on and
that, and that. There you go.
That's my German Sana
story. But I have, I got to,
I do have to tell you this though.
If you're completely naked in a sauna,
it's even better. It is even
better. It's fucking weird.
But you only can do it in a place. If
everybody's naked, then it isn't weird.
It isn't weird. And, uh,
if you're worried that you're going to
get a stiffy cause there's a naked woman
in there. There's also no other naked
men in there. So it neutralizes it.
Not to mention it's hot as shit.
Like I don't think anybody has ever
fucked in one of those hot naked, uh,
you know, the, that naked, the hot
yoga class, what do they call that?
The Bikram Yoga.
Like you can barely survive.
Fucking somebody is the last thing on
your mind when you're sitting at like 180
degree heat. But, uh,
anyways, bears my, um,
that was my, a story. It was hilarious.
I was worried that my junk was going to
look too small when I got into the ice
bath and I was worried that I was going
to fucking salute the Germans when I was
in the sauna. I would, you know, for
naked woman walked in, but it didn't,
I just felt like a fucking
creep. Um, so anyways,
and that's why you travel
the world every body.
Okay.
To get stories like
that. All right. Anyways,
all right, follow up. Should
girl have paid for dinner?
Now this became something on reddit
where I was reading this thing where,
uh, this guy, the way I read
it in the way I understood it,
now granted I was jet
lagged flying around Europe.
I thought he was saying that he took
his girlfriend out for a birthday dinner
with his parents and when the bill
came she had to pay for her meal.
So she was upset about that.
And then now he invited to another family
gathering and she made some flippant
comment asking him she'd have
to pay for the gas to get there.
And I sided with her going through it.
You can't make somebody pay for
their birthday meal. So anyways,
somebody had read it,
said Billy got a little confused with
that email about the birthday dinner.
The boyfriend's family weren't expecting
the girlfriend to pay for her own
birthday dinner.
They were expecting her to pay for
our own meal at his birthday dinner.
Oh, okay. The email said this, I think
he was just a little bit too jet lagged.
All right, well my mistake, um,
it's a little spoiled for her to get
that dinner and instantly expect to go to
that dinner and instantly
expect her meal be paid for.
I wouldn't really say I come from a
family of means, but we're not broke.
And when I've gone out for
dinner for my birthday,
my folks have always been happy to pay.
However,
my partner never just assume this.
It's rude to, I agree with that.
But having said that,
I would also pay,
I wouldn't make my girlfriend pay
for the meal. Um, even if you seek,
if you're secretly hoping someone else
pays through meal when it's not a special
occasion celebrating something for you,
just don't sit there and assume a,
the text message asking if she expected
to pay for own gas is astounding in its
level of rudeness to, I don't think
that that's rude because I think that's,
that's her reacting to being upset that,
um,
she was made to pay for
her own meal. Uh, yeah.
And then I actually see the
boyfriend's point, if that's exactly,
if that's how it was
worded. I mean, I can just,
I understand why she assumed that they
would have taken care of both of them.
Cause it was his birthday. It was a
special occasion and she's also a guest.
She's company, you know what I mean? I
understand that. That makes sense to me.
Um, so I, I actually,
I still side with the, uh,
with the woman on this one.
I kind of get it. Like if my parents
didn't pick up for my wife's meal,
I would have paid for it. I
Dunno. Anyways. Um, anyways,
it's not,
it's not remotely spoiled for the girl
to assume that the meal was paid for.
I'm on her side 100% I cannot remember
a single time growing up where I was
invited out to dinner with a friend's
family and I was expected to pay for my
own meal. Yeah. It's one of those
things if you're going out as a couple,
like two couples are going out,
then you split it anyways.
Now that I am an adult
with kids of my own,
I would be incredibly embarrassed to ask
my son's girlfriend to pay for own meal
at his birthday.
I am a,
I agree with that 100% now the text
message was passive aggressive,
but I think the meal thing
and the boyfriend's reaction
to it was so egregious
that I don't have a problem with
it. I don't either. I don't either.
I side with them to anyways and another
one, I'm sorry. Supposed to say any way.
I like saying anyways,
I used the ways app.
Why can't I say anyways?
I can not believe anyone doesn't have the
same answer as you. Haha Jesus Christ.
Where did these animals grow up?
I would die of embarrassment
if I was at a restaurant,
my with my family and my girlfriend and
my girlfriend and my dad asked her for
money. Yeah, I agree with you. You know,
I just think that maybe were braver,
maybe were the warriors
social justice warriors.
Hey,
you know what's great about doing this
podcast this early is my daughter's not
gonna be up for like
another hour. And so, um,
I get to hang all morning with her.
I bought her all these cool
sneakers when I was over there. Um,
she's like good until she's like three
or four years old because I got the size
wrong,
the size I was told to get.
I thought when she was that size now and
it turns out that that was, you know,
the next size up. So I got
two sizes in, three sizes up,
but they're all cool sneakers.
Well Thea,
all cool sneak attack got when
I was told three in Germany,
a jet lag. Hey Billy, numb nuts. Um,
try
Valerian tea to help reset your
sleep cycle while traveling.
It also helps take the edge off at the
end of the day when the whiskey blanky is
not an option. B L A N K Y is
not an option. Works for me. Uh,
I will definitely do that because
I'm 52 days in and not drinking.
And um, had I not done that
thrash, I would actually look good.
People were taking pictures of me.
I was like, I look fucking horrible.
Like just lack of sleep.
That's all we did for 10 days straight.
Fly in,
go to the hotel,
go do a show or to go back to the hotel,
sleep,
try to go to sleep and then you'd have
to get up at seven to take a train or
something like that.
And um, the younger me,
I would have looked fresh as
a daisy if I wasn't drinking,
but I was looking at those pictures.
I was like,
I might as well have been doing fucking
meth out here. Um, I will try that.
I actually got some Melatonin when I was
over there that everybody says is all
natural, but I got to tell you, it makes
you feel a little buzzed. Um, I dunno.
I Dunno about that Shit,
but it definitely helped me go to sleep.
I'm fat fellow speaking here. Uh, hello,
Mr. Bend, Bender, ovary bender over bill.
I don't know what that means.
I am 19 years old.
Five seven on a good day in
320 pounds. All right, dude,
you got to do something about that.
Thank God you got a young heart, but you,
you will not be five, seven, you know,
in your sixties at 320 pounds.
And I'm,
I'm not a doctor and I know this is a
fact. Anyways, I just wanted to ask you,
as a heavy fellow who tries very hard
to be kind and courteous to those around
him,
how can I be better?
I purposely avoid planes in public
transportation because I understand how
uncomfortable it must be for
others to even be around me.
It is very difficult because I have an
irrational fear of driving and there are
no taxi or Uber services in my area.
Um, I legitimately tried to
keep to myself, for example,
in a grocery store,
if I have to pass someone who is shopping,
I apologize simply because
I block half the aisle.
Most of the time folks are very
kind and shore missed the bar.
How can I be better to other folks who
are less girthy. Thank you for your time.
Um,
what I got out of that service,
I think that you need to come out of your
shell and I probably maybe go get some
therapy and maybe part of your reason
for eating and all of that type of stuff.
Is there a,
that seems to be a little bit of self
loathing going on here and God knows I was
the king of that. It just didn't
manifest itself into overeating.
It manifested itself in the
other shit that I've, I've,
I'm still trying to work out. But, um,
maybe if you start going to therapy,
you start reading up on nutrition and a,
I got to tell you, dude, if you five,
seven, 320 pounds, like, I mean,
I would think that you'd be able to
drop a lot of weight if he just started
eating right, because you obviously
don't need all of that on you. Um,
and then I think as,
as you learn about yourself in therapy
and then she started to drop weight,
um,
you're going to come out of your shelf
because you're not going to have to have
those feelings that you're being, you
know, you're just like a sensitive person.
The fact that you actually care, it's,
you have ear, an empathetic person.
And a lot of times people who are really
empathetic can get in their heads and
can get really, like,
I just think, you know,
I feel like that made me sad reading that.
So I don't want you walking around being
sad. You're in the prime of your life.
Like, and what's great is the fact
that you've five, seven, 320 pounds,
you have a great before picture.
All right,
so you got that checked off
your bucket list. Now you can,
you can turn this whole
fucking thing around
and you're so young that you,
you got your whole life ahead of,
you can just turn that
around and find out.
I would literally go to therapy and just
put it all out on the fucking table.
You know what you feel your problem is,
what you're afraid of,
what makes you cry and all of that Shit.
And then I would,
I would just start literally
marching towards getting in shape.
It'll help your fucking confidence.
And then what's great is,
is when you become a good looking guy
that's out there, fucking slammed it.
And the ladies are loving you. You know,
you've had the experience of being five,
seven, three 20 so you won't be a
fucking asshole. I remember one time,
I was on a plane a long, long, long
fucking time ago, like 15 years ago.
And I was sitting next to this
woman who was a fucking knock out,
an absolute knock out. And I sat down
next to her and she was just like, hey,
how you doing? And I was
like, good. I, you know, women
who looked that good don't,
aren't like that,
you know,
and it's not just because you know,
this stuck up.
It's because when they're
that good looking,
if they even remotely make
eye contact with another man,
they're now going to have to deal
with them hitting on them, you know,
so she was totally open with so fucking
cool and we're just shooting the shit.
She was talking to me like she was like
a widget salesman instead of like a
fucking 10. And then the
end, I finally had a Segway,
I'm going to be honest with you,
I've never,
I've never been around a
woman as good looking as you,
that was like this outgoing had your
personality, your personality is amazing.
And she laughed. She Cause Ah,
she goes, I used to be fat,
so I'm sure you already, you
already got the personality. So, um,
you know what you are you
like a great barn. Find in a,
in like the automotive industry.
I'm not calling you a fucking cow.
I'm saying like, you know,
when they go into Barnes,
they'll find this great old car that
they then restore and everybody fucking
loves it. So there you go. We're still
yourself, sir. That's what I would do.
And uh, and I believe in you. I think he
can do it. She's just put your mind to it.
But I think you just got to
figure out why you're uh,
you know why you are the way you are.
Because I know just being courteous and
empathetic isn't all you who you are.
You've got shit to say. You got hope.
She got dreams you want to find love.
So let's go. Let's get after it.
Get your ass out there. All right,
girlfriend won't lose weight.
It's all about weight. This,
uh, this week here, dear Billy, not
so fat. Thank you. I'll take that.
That's exactly what I am.
I'm not so fat,
but I definitely had a little too
much English did. So, yeah. Uh,
my girlfriend and I had been dating
for three years going on four and I'm
starting to have different
feelings towards her because
of her eating habits and
the way she takes care of herself.
Since I met her several years ago,
she kind of had a weight thing
that was noticeable. You know what,
I just fucking flaked reading this.
I gotta start over again.
I was just thinking how amazing it is
that Joe Rogan has Mike Tyson on his
podcast.
Um,
and I remember being on his podcast early
on where it was just in his house and
how far he's come with that podcast
is fucking amazing. I'm sorry,
I don't know why I was thinking of
that. Anyways, dear Billy, not so fat.
My girlfriend and I have been dating
for three years going on four and I'm
starting to have different
feelings towards her because
of her eating habits and
the way she takes care of herself. Um,
yeah, that isn't fair to do to somebody,
you know.
Um,
and I think it's when the guy puts on way
then if a woman comes on TV and was to
talk about that type of stuff, they would
side with her for expressing herself.
But if a guy does it, you're a
fucking asshole. Um, anyways,
since I met her several
years, that's your job, man.
You got to keep yourself looking good.
You got to keep the spark going in
50% of that is your responsibility.
Um, since I met her
several years ago, she had,
she came, she had kind of had a
weight thing that was noticeable,
but then think anything of it because
I thought she would get on some sort of
kick of wanting to lose some
weight in the years to come.
I thought you were gonna say,
I didn't mind because she was only a
little overweight and I liked her as a
person.
You're like, wow, you know,
I'll get her on the treadmill.
You, we got some potential here.
And what's funny is that's how women
look at men differently. All right,
he's got this job,
you know,
maybe you'll get to this job will
start making that kind of money.
I'll get him some new clothes. I can
work with this. I can fix him up.
And there's nothing wrong with that, you
know, there's nothing wrong. You know,
I used to, when I was younger, it used to
bother me, but it doesn't bother me that,
uh, a woman asked the guy what
he does for living. It's like,
what is she supposed to do?
Breed with a loser. Okay.
Why don't you like me for
who I am? Uh, you know,
cause I don't want to live
in a shack. All right, well,
it's been three and a half
years and there's no stopping
her from losing weight.
She's 25 and I'm 30 and
I don't know what to do.
She loves to sweets and is not a fan
of running because it hurts her feet.
Oh boy.
We'll get her on an elliptical.
Okay.
Oh hell bill help bill.
I love her,
but I don't want to spend my early
thirties miserable in a relationship with
someone who doesn't want to take care of
herself. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
I have to tell you something right now,
Dude.
You are in the most difficult
fucking position you can possibly be.
And as a man,
one of the hardest fucking conversations
you can have with a girlfriend other
than I'm breaking up with you,
is I,
this is even harder because
if you break it up with them,
they're going to cry and then
you're not gonna see him again.
Eventually they're going to move on.
You're going to try to
stay in a relationship.
Are you going to try to tell a woman,
okay,
that she needs to lose weight?
MMM.
I gotta be honest with
you. I'm an, you know what?
I'm going to bring the lovely Nia on
my next podcast and we're going to,
we're going to revisit
this question because,
okay,
I don't know how to do this because
you know,
I've been,
I've been lucky enough that I've always
been with women that like they, you know,
they want to go out and get
after it or whatever, you know,
hit the gym or whatever.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know. I don't, I wouldn't
know how to do this because this is,
this is so fucking fragile.
This is literally,
if you start talking about a woman's
weight is in the same world as if she
started talking about your Dick size or
your ability to satisfy her in the bed
because you're really talking now
like a woman won't, some of them,
their biggest power of ridiculous
power a woman has is her beauty.
You know,
I know they're all out there right now
trying to act like they're going to start
their own fucking airline and all of that
shit. I'm not saying don't go do that,
but like you know,
that is if you, if you're basically
saying that you're not attracted to them,
it's, you know, if, if my wife
came at me and said, hey man,
you're getting a little bit fat,
I would fucking laugh and it
would so fucking motivate me.
And to the point,
I wish she would say it to me cause
I want to tape a special soon. Uh,
but I got to go with self motivation
here of taking of all the tweets.
I'm going to get it from a fat
fuck am my special. But um, yeah,
this is a really difficult thing.
Um, don't have the conversation.
It's all Nia comes on.
And even after what Nia says,
I would also try to get advice
from women in your life and
you have to start it with,
I love my girlfriend,
I love it to death.
We just have a problem and I don't
know how to bring it up. Okay.
If you do that, the woman you're
talking to will be more open minded,
I think to listen to you.
However,
if you start with my girlfriends
fat and I'm not attracted to it,
what the fuck they,
they might get defensive and start
defending her and say that you're shallow.
They, that's certainly going
to happen on the Internet. Um,
so whatever. Good luck with that and
I'll try to help you out on Thursday. Uh,
thinking about breaking up with
my girlfriend. Okay, here we go.
Dear Billy, not so fat. Look at this
shit. I got a couple of those, right.
Wait a second.
All this is the same fucking person
dear. Uh, my girlfriend and I
had been dating for three. Wait,
did I just say one is to, this guy's
brilliant girlfriend won't lose weight.
And now thinking about breaking up with
my girlfriends from the exact same guy
there,
Billy not so fat.
My girlfriend and I had been dating for
three years and going on foreign and
starting to have different feelings
towards this is the exact same fucking,
I was fucking hilarious. Wait
a second. Is it? It has to be,
it's written a little bit
different. I'll still read it. Uh,
since I've met her several years ago.
She's Kinda had a weight thing
that that was noticeable,
but I didn't think anything of it because
I thought she would get on some sort
of check of wanting to lose the way the,
as the, it's been three and a half years.
There's no sign lose, lose weight. She's
25 and 30. It's exact same fucking guy.
Alright. Okay Dude. Well then what
I did that's fucking brilliant.
Fucking brilliant. Um, I would say this.
Yeah,
you have to make the decision right now.
Okay.
Um,
do you love your girlfriend in a way
that you want to stay with her eventually
marry her and help her
through this problem or
did you sort of sort of thought,
you found I'm going to marry you
love but just sort of found love,
love and now that she's overweight
and you're not as attracted to her,
is that feeling starting to come up?
You know what I mean?
Cause that really is, that's when you
find out if you really love somebody,
anybody can be around during the
good times. Right? You're a man,
you're making a bunch of money. You
can take her to fucking, you know,
France or whatever, you know,
she's a chick and she's fucking,
you know,
go into crossfit and crushing it and
fucking look hot that you ignore,
you know? But when,
when shit hits the fan,
okay, and you have to be there for
somebody emotionally or what are,
you have to accept some of their flaws.
Uh,
that's when you find out if you love,
love somebody. You know what I mean?
I'm not saying that you
don't think about leaving.
Everybody thinks about
leaving all the fucking time.
I don't need this fucking
Shit fucking shit.
You're fucking and everything and
I'll fucking get it. You know? I know.
I love my wife to death is,
even in my fantasies when I'm mad is
I can possibly be at her even in my
fantasies.
I can't break up with her.
I get to the point where
she starts walking out of
the house and then I get sad
and I run out and hug her.
So there you go.
Okay. So there's a good question
for you and your fantasy.
Can you break up with somebody and you
feel all right about now that isn't a
good litmus test because then I'm
doing the arrogant thing that you're,
you're wired exactly the way
that I am. Um, anyways, uh,
any way I am, I am back from
Europe. I have to tell you,
that was one of the greatest experiences
I've ever had as somebody in this
business, the business of show, you know,
trying to figure out those crowds.
Trying to remember how the vibe I had the
last time I was over there and it took
me a few shows have hit
or misses to figure out,
to find tune the thing like a fucking
race car. And I watched Versie do it too.
And I'm at, I'm going to call
this right now with Paul Versey,
that fucking guy after that set I saw
him do at Gotham and then watching him
going over to Europe, nervous
saying to me, Gone Bell,
I know I'm probably going to take a
couple of fucking hits over here and I'm
going, no, you're not, dude. You're
going to be fine. You're gonna be fine.
Knowing that he was that kind of watching
him figure it out to the point that by
the time we went to Vienna, the
people booking it there, we're,
we need to have you back. We need
to have you come back here. Um,
I'm just really proud of him because I
always knew that he was going to be able
to do shit like that and
his specials crushing it,
and he's got a big tour coming up and
I'm going to lose him as an opener.
Um, which is I, which is what I want
for anybody who ever opens for me.
You know what I mean? I never want
to have a lifer opener, you know?
That's like having the kid that
never moved out of your house.
It's like, son, get out there and
find love. Um, all right. That is it.
God bless all you go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Hey. Oh, by the way, I think
I'm doing a podcast with that.
That guy there I was telling you about
that he comes across like an old school,
uh, it old school, a sports announcer,
like a Dick shap kind of guy way back.
You know it's going to,
you'd be like the best, the base, the
best patriots coverage in the business.
He actually DMD me,
so I started following him.
They William?
Yeah.
Bended. B And d. E. T. S. O. N. A.
Where the fuck are we going to be?
Oh,
I told them sometime around January
15th. I was going to do it. What's today?
Today's the 14th. All right. I
got to reach out to this guy.
We're going to do a podcast
talking patriots and I'll get,
I'll send out a link and all that
type of stuff. Uh, hopefully, uh,
because this guy seems like he
really knows the Patriots. I don't,
on the other hand, I,
I'm, I'm, uh, I'm, uh,
I watch as much as I can watch with the
travel and the kid. All right. Anyways,
go fuck yourselves. I'll check
in on you on Thursday. See Ya.